trois auditions sans suite judiciaire
l'enquêté sur l'assassinât du petit
grégory piétine depuis que son corps
ligoté été retrouvé dans la vologne près
d'epinal le 16 octobre dernier
monsieur madame laroche le couple qui
avait été placé en garde à vue mercredi
et qui a été libéré hier le couple a
accepté de rencontrer isabelle bechler à
brouillet roulant 4 semble marquer le
pas tout le monde est dans l'incertitude
nous avons rencontré le couple laroche
suspect jusqu'à hier encore celle michel
villemin l'oncle de grégory les
graphologues eux affirme toujours que
bernard laroche est le corbeau jean
normand soupçonné parce que j'avais une
écriture qui ressemblait à celle du
corbeau jeu m'a plu que c'était pour moi
j'ai l'accord sas traquer et ils n'ont
pas pu prouver ce témoin mais pourtant
d'après les dernières informations qu'on
l'a on a l'impression que les gendarmes
en sont toujours persuadés et la justice
aussi alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous pouvez dire ça je suis que les
jardins seront toujours persuadé que
c'est moi mère sourit joue 10 je sais
que c'est pas moi
ça je ne peux pas apporter de preuves
tant que sa bombe à sous utilisés en cas
des spécialistes des graphologues qui
connaissent leur boulot pour prouver que
c'était moi ouais j'espère que nous
arriverons à trouver qu'ils se trompent
vous étiez vous aviez un alibi pour
cette heure là j'aimerais être sûr qu'il
m'a vu rater les rangs de l'école roman
alors là j'ai eu guère que ça comme
alibi apport j'étais chez un ami
lagrange personne ne m'a vu ce sont à la
conscience tranquille
je crois que c'est ça qui nous a sauvés
selon les milieux proches de l'anc est
lé témoignage du couple permettent
cependant aux gendarmes de progresser
dans leurs investigations